[Musique]
dilan enfants l'école des fans comme les
adultes les petits ont aussi le droit à
leur heure de gloire à la télé par
hachette
si les émissions avec des enfants ont
toujours plus ou moins existé elles
viennent à se populariser
c'est au rêve c'est maintenant the voice
kids eurovision junior les productions
adam de plus en plus leurs formats aux
enfants mais cette médiatisation
soudaine des petits n'est pas sans
risque apprécions harcèlement à l'école
et jalousie à cet âge-là difficile
d'encaisser des coups comme l'avait
expliqué la candidate deux heureuses kid
satine pas ce qui s'est passé c'est à
l'école genre à l'école harcèlement
scolaire en fait on pense que c'est de
la jalousie et ça a été quelque chose à
presque dans soutenable en fait elle
n'est pas la seule à avoir connu la
célébrité très jeune jordi jean baptiste
maunier priscilla betti pour eux aussi
dû faire face aux critiques et ton petit
à mon âge c'est vrai je suis sorti j'ai
pleuré dans les bras d'un moment puisque
forcément ça va ça va un peu touchés
alors êtes vous content les enfants à la
télé
alors vont contre les enfants à la télé
contre oui je suis content déjà j'aime
pas les enfants
mais là je rigole je vis avec des
enfants les enfants des autres et les
enfants des autres alors ça et tout
jeunes enfants de familles non j'adore
les enfants mais moi j'ai exposé ne
votent pas comme ça tu vois c'est très
dangereux d'être exposé à la notoriété
la célébrité je parle évidemment des
enfants qu'on met à la télévision oussou
même parfois sur instagram je trouve
cette année après on n'a pas là on va
sur la télé si tu veux d'accord moi je
trouve c'est un danger parce que c'est
très violent la célébrité les enfants
apprennent dans leur cour de récréation
ils se font ils sont isolés et enfin
c'est non ils sont isolés forces armées
mallié bernard métais un même panier de
buzz qui par exemple et l'école des fans
oui c'est bien qu'ils aient qu'on leur
donne leur chance nomme épisodes qu'on
leur donne une chance de chanter tu sais
si c'est le rêve etc c'est très bien
mais je trouve que d'accéder à une
notoriété comme ça aussi rapidement sans
trop de préparation c'est violent la
notoriété c'est violent et c'est
destructeur surtout pour un enfant qui
n'est pas encore vraiment fort mais
psychologiquement le livre du mois chez
michmich en fait parce que alors je
rejoins un petit peu ce que dit bernard
mais pas totalement moi je suis pour les
enfants qui ont choisi d'être à la télé
qui ont choisi de faire du cinéma parce
que très tôt un enfant c'est ce qu'il a
envie de faire vanessa paradis quand
elle a fait l'école des fans c'était un
voeu perso et regarder la carrière
qu'elle a eu derrière moi je pense que
le danger en fait ce sont les enfants
qui sont exposées contre leur gré font
pas nécessairement envie d'être sur les
réseaux que les parents veulent utiliser
comme moyen de se faire pour ce faire de
l'oseille en fait moi je suis plutôt je
suis plutôt pour moi j'ai un enfant
apparemment dernier sait ce qu'il veut
il vous faire des photos auxquelles je
vais emmener faire des trucs maintenant
il ya des enfants qui n'ont pas envie de
ça et il ya des parents fait qu'ils s'en
servent uniquement pour faire de
l'oseille et c'est là que ça devient
toxique ça ce sera pour le 2ème volet
oui il ya des enfants et en amérique
pour m'étonner foster et comme c'est
très bien ça à la traîne et réussit mal
tourné la petite fille de deux ans
elle a plongé
jamais plongé c'est un enfant disney
vous voyez oui mais si vous regardez ça
c'est les systèmes aux états unis ou en
france c'est plutôt bien gérer parce que
quand les enfants de travail il faut
savoir par exemple on a fui a fait des
photos parce qu'elle a voulu en faire
plus tard ya là c'est la caisse des
dépôts et ses serres que les parents ne
pêche pas ils dorment chez moi que c'est
devenu une affaire jour dit oui c'est ça
quand les parents n'ont plus accès à
l'argent les enferme dans les parents
ont accès à une partie oui pour
l'entretien à la
course enfants restent protégés là tu
sers que c'est leur argent dont ses
parents peuvent - je veux dire abusé
entre guillemets de notoriété ou de la
mise en avant des enfants et ça c'est
vachement maire s'il n'ya pas aux états
unis je vais vous dire juste une
parenthèse vous pourrez enfin vous avez
évoqué jordi l'a évoquée tandis que j'ai
reçu moi le petit jordy on a dû répéter
je sais pas combien de fois ils étaient
fatigués ce jour là c'était la une est à
vous samedi après midi en direct sur tf1
il pleurait sans arrêt et moi j'ai
j'avais le coeur brisé il est par
ailleurs est tu nous emmerdes alléchante
mais ça c'est
des images ou dans cette interview
d'enfants qui ont écrit qu'ils sont
poussés par des parents c'est ça c'est
terrible alors vous vous êtes content de
bord alors je suis croire de la vie des
enfants de la télé voilà mais là deux
types de programmes pour pour moi on a
les programmes un peu style incroyable
talent etc qui eux me dérange pas plus
que ça ça peut leur créer des souvenirs
c'est leur passion n'y a pas de souci
mais les programmes un peu plus télé
réalité c'est une famille nombreuse et
c'est ça ça me dérange un peu plus je
sais mais si vous vous souvenez mais
dans un tellement vrai y avait une jeune
fille que sap et mélissandre et qui
avait été filmée parce qu'ils avaient
des problèmes de poids etc il y avait
une scène que tout le monde connaît ou
sa mère lui dit tu es grosse laine etc
j'étais parti à sa recherche gd des
passions bizarre mais j'étais reparti à
sa recherche elle m'avait répondu et
elle m'avait dit que ça avait ruiné il
savait tout ça de jeunesse et le nouvel
élu jamais avare être à l'antenne vous
parlez de famille xxl il y avait un pays
ça et ça en fait c'est une émission ou
en fait ils mettent en avant des
familles ils ont fait don de 8 enfants
et ils ont été bons ils ont été très
connue très vite et il ya eu des
conséquences évidentes pour eux on a un
extrait
séquelles mis la table à la tu sais pas
ce qu'a dit c'est pas moi qui ai mis la
table
beaucoup c'est qu'il est très joueuse
schiste perd sa maman
vous êtes malesan souffler et vous
poussez juste un tout petit
[Musique]
c'est un bonheur non on peut pas se
lasser de donner la vie
tu rigoles à bondues balle toi j'ai
pensé à faire l'étoile et en patois
ouais ouais j'ai tout raté même utile et
pas fait oui oui comme ça l ecosoc
pourquoi tu m'étonnes non tu as pas fait
si t'as pas vu un t6 les faire je sais
quand je suis je sais que je peux être
insupportable elle sait très bien m'a
dit tu es venu sur la wii mais vous vous
avez en charge entre guillemets amandine
votre avis avec elle oui oui ça a été un
mandine et c'est une femme qui est hyper
heureuse qui y perd
oui elle s'est fait attaquer mais c'est
une femme elle est très attaquée
attention à perdre mais pour elle elle
s'en est sorti parce qu'elle a eu
beaucoup trop et aussi avant elle a eu
une très très difficile amandine et est
en fait moi aujourd'hui je la vois vivre
et elle l aime elle aime la vie elle
aime les enfants et les hadjis tels que
et fort ses enfants quoique moi je les
ai vus les petits ils sont venus à la
maison vous garantir qu'ils étaient
meilleurs super épanouie est-ce que
c'était lui sur l'aura changer vraiment
leur lors qu'elle était due au fait je
pense que oui sinon on va pas se mentir
hypocrite oui oui évidemment mais je
pense pas qu'ils aient fait cette
émission pour ça parce que en vraie
famille n'ont pas faim famille nombreuse
s'était papin prédit comme une émission
de télé réalité où ça allait sortir des
influenceurs pardon d'ailleurs il y en a
certains dans les missions qu'on connaît
pas contents qu'on a manqué en effet à
préciser que sa relation qu'on voit sur
les réseaux parce qu'elle s'expose
beaucoup elle adore ça et elle en vit
très bien mais bien sûr ea pas ya des
moments dans cette émission large part
pas avec les enfants d'amandine mais
d'autres enfants quand les enfants
soient en itv en interview vous savez le
moment où ils sont aux anges d'annoncés
de confessionnal ils sont là en train de
bâiller gens peuvent les yeux et
répondre des réponses genre vas-y abrège
parce que j'en peux plus ces moments là
moi ça me gêne profondément normal on
mélange il ya des lois comme il ya des
enfants et blessé 13 ans qu'est trois
heures par jour je crois même mais voilà
et aux bulls est contre oui parce qu'on
parlait des enfants qui choisissez entre
guillemets la médiatisation là je ne
pense pas qu'ils aient choisi je pense
que fait les parentés cervelli ça il ya
une différence entre faire faire des
photos à son enfant ou une apparition
dans un film être médiatisé tous les
jours sur une chaîne comme tf1 devant 2
3 millions de téléspectateurs c'est une
notoriété énorme et il suffit qu'ils
aient une séquence on part de tellement
vrai souffle alors on se moque de
l'enfant ça peut donner lieu à du
harcèlement à des dérives sur l'anneau
sociaux et malheureusement ça ça reste
et l'enfant ne choisit pas donc pour moi
la télévision pour les enfants c'est
extrêmement dangereux et ce qui est
regrettable c'est que on va en parler
mais sur les réseaux aussi les parents
parfois s'en servent pour se mettre en
avant et ou pour leur faire vivre la
carrière que aurait aimé avoir
bertand vous pourrez peut-être parler du
du côté mercantile peut-être c'est en
amérique pour le coup que ça va naître
et sa date de l'antéchrist j'ai envie de
dire on remonte au cinéma muet 1921 il
ya ce film de charlie chaplin
il tourne chine ce qui va être vraiment
un grand classique un des tout premiers
films du cinéma il a comme héros à petit
garçon de 7 ans jackie coogan et jackie
cogan quand il va avoir l âge de pouvoir
disposer de son argent alors qu'il a
engrangé des millions ils gagnent 4
millions $ à l'époque on vient de faire
un malheur c'est énorme
le père a tout dilapidé et il va falloir
attendre 1939 pour que naisse une loi
qui va porter son nom la jac ian l'eau
et qui désormais en amérique va venir
centralisé un peu le côté argent que
peuvent gagner les enfants alors les
parents auront le droit ont le droit
absolument de de pouvoir toucher à cette
somme d'argent en partir mais tout est
né j'ai ferrer désormais en amérique
d'un point de vue argentique à je ne
sais pas en france le parlement s'est
passé autre sujet un peu plus compliqué
les enfants sur les réseaux sociaux
alors moi je reconnais moi j'ai fait des
photos de mon fils le dernier mai
dernier fils en général j'aime et sur
les réseaux bon il n'y a pas pour
l'instant de conséquence vous magali
votre fille ça a été plus compliqué oui
mais ma fille elle est déscolarisé
c'est d'étendre ses des conséquences
dramatiques et puis et puis bon je vais
pas tout raconter parce que c'est trop
compliqué puis j'ai pas envie mais mais
mais effectivement c'est c'est un drame
alors je suis pour pourquoi je suis pour
jouer vous expliquer parce que pour les
reds je vais vous je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi c'est très paradoxal mais j'ai
eu cette discussion avec ma fille est
vraiment on en a discuté les mois c'est
que c'est pas aux enfants d'être puni en
fait alors les enfants doivent pas avoir
d compte instagram en dessous de 13 ans
et c'est ça y'a pas de débat donc pas
pour les moins de 13 ans pas pour les
ados c'est pas aux ados d'être puni de
vivre une adolescence pour des gens qui
sont mal intentionnées c'est les
coupables qu il faut qu'il faut punir
c'est pas les enfants qui vivent leur
vie peut pas empêcher un enfant moi je
pouvais pas dire à ma fille ok t'es ma
fille donc toi t'as pas d'instagram
parce qu'elle m'aurait reproché ça toute
sa vie de pas pouvoir vivre son
adolescence normalement à cause de moi
donc effectivement je les laissais en
contrôlant les choses en regardant j'ai
accès à son compte instagram il n'y a
pas de souci la petite n'en a pas
pourquoi mon officine en a pas parce que
ma fille m'a dit bah j'en veux pas maman
moi j'ai pas envie de me montrer sur les
réseaux et souvent
parce que j'ai trois enfants j'ai trois
enfants moi j'en ai une la toute petite
qui adore ça et que ça y est me faire ça
avec sa soeur qui la connaît il lâché
ligne et puis à victoria qui est très
discret lui très réservé a toujours dit
maman moi j'ai pas envie donc on la sna
pas et bizarrement on se fait insulter
aussi pour ça les gens disent oui à
moscou la finale elle que les autres et
non c'est juste qu'en fait je respecte
le choix de ma fille elle n'a pas envie
de se montrer je montrerai pas alors
justement puisqu'on parle d des réseaux
on a une vidéo de 2 par an en amérique
qui sont qui pousse en renfort pour
faire des vues banon ils vont jusqu'à
humilier leurs enfants et oui c'est
abominable regardée aux états unis les
parents vont de plus en plus loin avec
des mises en scène de plus en plus trash
face à ces dérives la justice américaine
commence à sévir les parents de la
famille martin ont perdu la garde de
deux de leurs cinq enfants suite à ce
sketch où ils terrorisent leurs fiscaux
dix neuf ans en l'accusant d'une bêtise
qu'il n'a pas commises qu'est ce que
c'est que ce bordel mais je n'ai jamais
fait ça il était devenu le souffre
douleur médiatique de la famille
je n'ai jamais fait ça mais tu es encore
en train de nous mentir
c'était une blague les gars
[Rires]
c'est qu'ils perdent la grèce et une
dose enfant est pas d or et par an
je suis désolé je vais aller contre ce
que vous pensez tous mais heureusement
il ya les réseaux sociaux pour montrer
ça pour que les enfants soient retirés
non ça parce que ça c'est grave c'est de
la maltraitance et si personne n'avait
les six avaient pas la région sud loire
en fait cette scène ces gamins ont des
soucis
aux mises en scène la
maltraitance et la maltraitance c'est ce
qui se passe effectivement c'est très
grave nous on n'a pas de super nanny
c'est l'heure des programmes qui avec
simon fun à regarder les phobiques un
enfant s'est calmée ruines érable c'est
des enfants qui ont qu'ils sont enfants
qui sont ados qui font des crises et qui
vont se retrouver en fait avec ce
fardeau toute leur vie comme tu parlais
de mélisse entre thaler ils ont gardé
les droits pendant cinq ans a été
diffusée tous les matchs tous les mois
elle se faisait harceler elle a vécu un
calvaire un enfer je vois par exemple
n'y a pas si longtemps le fils de julien
tanti un influenceur star de thé wright
téléréalité son fils en fait donc
exposés il a demandé un certain bébés
exposés et en fait il a dû du mal à a
parlé du mal à marcher et c est se sont
fait laminer sur les réseaux sociaux en
disant que leur fille s'était attardé
qu'il était bête on est aimé des
horreurs et je me dis le gamin et bagram
désirant rester là les garçons avec un
extrait de soi et des autres
un
peu plus fatigué on les pousse encore
les fans défile pas le temps de discuter
avec leurs stars une photo et c'est au
tour du suivant
pour swan six ans le temps commence à
être long est ce qui se passe tu
t'endors
fait les tickets
swan est fatigué mais pour sophie il n'y
a pas de quoi s'inquiéter nous ne
demanderons pas à soi n'est ni eux aussi
en ont assez sophie nous a pris de ne
pas les interviewés pendant cette
rencontre
alors été c'est quoi c'est quand les
parents
beaucoup d'argent et le business croyez
moi et phénomène a eu deux dents dans
sept à huit on y verra un sujet sur ça
et vous allez voir que c'est vraiment du
business haut de gamme
3 128 mille personnes suivent lors
anthony et leurs enfants jusque dans les
moments les plus intimes
une vidéo vue par plus de 1 million de
personnes en sept ans 98 millions de
vues un succès qui commence à rapporter
beaucoup d'argent à la famille grâce à
la publicité diffusée pendant ces vidéos
lors touche de youtube entre 50 centimes
et 3 euros toutes les lignes
pour celle de l'accouchement par exemple
environ 1500 euros évidemment c'est
tentant
sur les réseaux il n'y a pas vraiment de
loi pas concernant l'exploitation entre
guillemets des enfants nous recenser pas
encadré pas de quoi je parle de global
honnêtement
je fais c'est
penseurs d'enfants une marque nous l'a
demandé est en fait nous on a souhaité
que ça passe par une agence de
mannequinat parce que c'est malgré la
rémunération des cadres et tout est
encadré mais il ya des nouvellois
regarder
une loi vient d'être votée pour encadrer
l'activité des enfants sur youtube elle
sera rattachée à celle déjà en vigueur
sur le travail des enfants dans le
cinéma et la publicité
les enfants n'auront pas le droit d'être
filmé plus de deux heures par jour
seulement le mercredi et le samedi ah
les jours d'école ni le dimanche et tous
devront avoir des contrats de travail
qui comprend qu'ils aient loi comme ça
pour protéger les enfants de son âge
bah oui parce que c'est quand même
important parce que et des enfants qui
peuvent peut-être en avoir marre du coup
bah c'est important quand même d'abord
cette loi pour un peu limité
oui cette loi elle est sympathique mais
quand ça se passe dans le cadre familial
comment peut-on check et que partant de
valeo et swan comment on va checker
qu'ils sont mais on n'est que deux de
ses sept lutins sont aujourd'hui sur les
réseaux il y avait la loi on sait très
bien et mégabits pour l'instant là les
lois sont en voie la wii est très floue
mais je pense que c'est les parents
effectivement c'est la responsable des
départs en passe comme ça on peut
revenir à julien et manon par exemple
c'est des gens qui ont toujours fait
attention à leur cissé qui ont jamais
voulu exposer chavo quand il n'en avait
pas envie tu vois et c'est je pense des
gens qui vont communiquer avec leurs
fils pour lui expliquer les choses et
puis tu as des parents donc ça c'est
positif en fait y'a pas de débat je mets
tu as des gens comme eux les parents de
swan qui les oblige à s'asseoir comme il
en a tant dérivé ago tu verras jamais
faire ça je vais dire ça ça n'existe pas
tu vois c'est y pas